This is the story about a birth like no other.
You see, Mama's in Perth right now and Dad is nearly 4,000 kilometers away.
A full day's travel by plane, working in a remote part of Queensland.
Life can sometimes keep people apart.
But even though they're on opposite sides of Australia,...
...they're about to experience the birth of their child together.
Virtually.
For the first time, Samsung VR technology will help bring people closer together,...
...so they can share moments that should never be missed.
As Allison went into labor,...
...we set about creating the world's first live virtual reality birth...
...using Samsung Gear VR.
In a matter of seconds, 4,000 kilometers disappeared.
And that's good, that's good.
It's gonna be alright.